brian hayes hitting 348 now
on the season
it's this hard the other way to stay
fair
it is gone it hit the pole an opposite
field home run
for key brian hayes one of the toughest
pitchers in the league
takes him right down the line after
seeing
all those balls up high they go
downstairs for the first time
with a 97 mile an hour fastball well now
the
dodgers are either asking for
a review of the home run or they also
appealed first base because hayes was
busting it out of the box
and they're claiming that maybe he
missed first base
what called a foul he did miss first
they're calling him out that's
unbelievable
holy smokes that's incredible it's
nothing nothing
again i've never seen that why wouldn't
he go back overall numbers for mueller
there his last four starts even better
he's got a one
seven three in that spin now now faces
the pitcher brubacher
faces loaded two gone no score in the
second maybe he did here
one two it's a slider rolled over the
mound to short
lux feeds taylor just in time at second
to end the inning mueller is able to
strand the bases loaded no score after
two
blue baker shot oh
nice pick by newman what were we saying
about making the plays it's short
but even when it's a super difficult
play like that one
it really didn't look flashy it just
kind of looked
smooth this is a bullet
jeez it just makes the play
takes his crow hop throws him out
yeah you're right he made that look
routine
here's pollock swinging in the first
pitch hitting a high fly ball to center
past the diving reynolds the dodgers
have the game's first run
pollock jumps on the first pitch and an
rbi double makes it one nothing
dave roberts talked about hey we're
gonna see what he has early on
make the adjustments well
so chris taylor make an adjustment now
we see aj pollock has a great effort out
there in center field by reynolds it was
just
out of reach off the tip of his glove
are you talking about his numbers aren't
as good as they have been in the past
even a pictures away i said well
a lot of it's a bat path coming
underneath the bat even the balls that
are in the middle of the plate
swats this one in the air right center
field back goes reynolds still
going lays out can't get it up against
the wall
[ __ ] can walk home that's sprinting
for third with an rbi triple
dodgers lead at two nothing what an
effort from reynolds but
couldn't quite get there hitting it hard
making an adjustment
that was a lot better with the swing
path the more tough hand and driving it
the other way
and also being able to hit his slider
talk about how effective it's been on
the glove side he got over the middle of
the plate
up until pollock the dodgers were oh for
seven versus
with three k's versus his slider pollock
at a slider mookie bets
his excellent job going the other way
with that slider and hustling all the
way to third
it was a really great effort out there
by reynolds that's a third two gone and
a 2-1 pitch to muncie
base hit right center three-nothing
dodgers as muncie drives in bets
that snaps it over 14 skid for muncie
three in the bank here in the fifth
inning one thing the dodgers have done
well this year is runners in scoring
position and two outs
that pitch is drilled left center field
forget about it home run chris taylor
sounded like a shotgun going off eighth
of the season for taylor and the dodgers
lead
5-0 great swing by chris taylor and the
pitcher knew it right away
this looks like a ball there's just a
hanging one up in the zone that's
exactly where you want it as a hitter he
stays on it
head down pitcher did stratton didn't
even look
like he's still just looking straight
straight and going listen just give me
just give me a belt
she looks to move to four and all over
his last five starts in era around one
and a half in that time
he's done it tonight a little bit
differently than he typically does just
two strikeouts
sky high pop-up
it's taylor and it's seven shutout
innings from walker mueller
the dodgers were kind of following that
road
just old fair a fair ball called
and frazier will extend the hitting
streak and he'll do it with a double
he likes to collect the doubles gets the
bucks on the board 11 straight games
77 hits to lead baseball and yep he is
the doubles
leader as well that's number 21. and
another base hit with a runner in
scoring position
he's really good in those situations
he's been excelling
at that also so everything pointed i
think to a double right there
adam frazier 21 doubles four runs up
so just looking for three outs non-save
situation
that's hammered to center field deep
clear the deck
cannonball coming an anchor down for
brian reynolds
he greets jones with his ninth of the
year absolutely rocket that's all
that's not one of those high drives that
gets out because you get the perfect
angle on it that's almost 108 miles an
hour
be interesting to see what reynolds ends
up with this year is a total for home
runs
trying to pull it takes it right back
over the top of the mound
as we said good chance albert pujols
will be in that lineup tomorrow for
la as michael perez sends one towering
to right field
a pinch hit clear the deck
michael perez makes it 5-3
fourth home run of the season for
michael perez
and that will be it as jansen is going
to have to come in
two outs but reynolds homer to start the
innings and now michael perez launches
one
no doubter both of them in this inning
and
right off the bat just another question
was how far was it gonna carry
evans one for three tonight he's single
to start last inning came in to score
their first run
he's trying to keep things alive jansen
has him in an o2 hole though
and strikes him out 90 93 95 and he
takes just three pitches to finish the
job oh you're coming in you didn't
expect to come in that's the way you do
it
go after right attack attack the zone
especially with a two run lead you're
like listen i'm you are not getting a
free pass i'm gonna put you away well
done
and keep myself available for tomorrow
yes to throw those three pitches
so the dodgers improve to two and two on
this road trip